bon à ce qu'elle tienne toutes leurs
responsabilités merci la parole est à
monsieur eric straumann merci merci le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
le numéro un mondial de l'électroménager
a annoncé ce mardi la fermeture de son
usine d'amiens qui compte 290 salariés
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
exprimé hier dans cet hémicycle votre
détermination à ne laisser aucun salarié
au bord du chemin
vous avez reçu le président de vire paul
qui est venu spécialement des etats-unis
pour lui rappeler que la loi florange
oblige des entreprises qui ferment à
mettre la totalité des moyens dont elle
dispose sur la table pour permettre la
reprise la poursuite de l'activité
industrielle et le maintien de la
totalité des emplois
hier sous la pression de françois long
de françois hollande notre président de
la république
le conseil d'administration d'edf a voté
un accord
actant la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim et donc la suppression de
2000 emplois
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
est simple et j'y associe mon collègue
michel sordi
allez-vous convoqué le président de la
république
comme vous l'avez fait avec le président
du 8 pool pour lui demander quelles sont
les propositions sérieuses et crédibles
de réindustrialisation du site de
fessenheim
merci merci la parole est à madame
ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député mesdames et
messieurs les députés ce sujet je pense
ne devrait pas nous opposer
je crois que nous avons à trouver
ensemble des solutions intelligentes
pour l'avenir et comme vous le savez
monsieur le député je ne peux pas
répondre plus ancienne de france
elle est construite sur une zone
sismique
elle bénéficie d'une dérogation ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui quand une centrale
est construite elle n'a plus le droit
d'utiliser le système de refroidissement
par coupage direct dans le rhin et que
cette autorisation en tout état de cause
de fonctionnement s'arrête au 31
décembre 2022 mais sans doute s'il ya
des contentieux avant cette date
c'est pourquoi nous avons la
responsabilité d'accompagner la mutation
industrielle de ce site
et comme vous le savez puisque ce
processus maintenant est en cours je
vais pouvoir débloquer les
investissements dans une dynamique
franco allemand puisque les allemands
avaient suspendu leurs investissements
industriels sur cette zone autour du
projet premièrement dû à l'installation
d'une usine de fabrication de batteries
de troisième génération pour les
véhicules électriques
deuxièmement nous allons pouvoir
repositionner ce territoire comme
territoires de projet pour
l'implantation de l'usiné
tesla qui doit venir en europe et
troisièmement je souhaite que ce site
devienne un site exemplaire en termes de
démantèlement des centrales nucléaires
puisque il ya 400 centrales nucléaires à
démanteler à travers le monde et par
conséquent il ya là une filière de
développement industriel majeur
j'ajoute que contrairement ce que vous
venez dire il n'y a pas de 1000
suppressions d'emplois la totalité des
emplois sont maintenus sur ce territoire
et plus le travailleront vite à la
mutation industrielle vers les emplois
du futur plu nous donnerons de l'espoir
à ce territoire qui le méritent